VENING
BEFORE WGITH  I WAN SSOMETHE
OUDES INVITED TO SITGHMANY OF YE
OFO ANSWER OWD
PREDICTABLY,
W LIE AFTER LIR E.I GET IT.
HE TA FORCEMENT OFFICEASEE
ADJECE USED
MANY TIMES TDESCRIBECKTHE
TO HIM.OR NASTY, WHICH IS WHATS
IT WAS DISTURBING TO HEAR
ON
CONSPIRATORS WHO ASSAULTEDN AS .
AND YOUNG AND OLD,W CIZETHEIND
WHO ACCORDING TO A JURY PEERS HS
DID TRYING THECK HIM, IT
IS IMPOSSIBLCHECK
FULLBESHAMELESSLY.
N
SHOULDN'T HAVE GIVEN H
AND I UNDERSTAND THE ABO
TH.
I GET THAT.
BUT THISWHATO
U HEAROMGHT, THAT MAN IS THE ON
NOMINATION PRESIDENT.
D ACCO POL REPUBLICAN CLO.OU TO.
AT AUDIENCING OF ABOTRY.
THEY ARE YOUR FAMILY, AND  ARE .
AND MANY SAID THEY'RE VOTING
PPEN ANVESTIGATION. F.EENTION T
NIGHOWED
ANDE IS HARD. CAN  A I
YOU HAVE EVERY RIGBE
OUTR ANGRY AND THRK AGA
THINK STAYING IN YOUR
Y LISTENING TO
PEOPLE YOU AGREE GOINGE  AY?L LE
ITY ACTUALLY
REALTIME, THOSE LD THOSE LIESA
UNDERSTAND, YOVEN ACTUALLYET
YOU CAMA
EVHE AISLE
AFTER LAST, NONE OF US CAN
SA KNO
THERE.DIDN'T COMING.
ASENATORS FOR
THT NIGHT. PREFERRED NOT TO
HEARD.RS DID.REMPLINGE
>> WHAT WAS TH
IN             ?
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S JUDGMENT IS
WRONG IN THIS CASE
GOVERNMENT HAVE ENGAGED IN W
CRIMES.
WHAT THEY WOULD GET WITH ATHLD
IDENT,S COMPLETELY
UNTETHEDE
RUSSIA ON TH TO WHETHE WANTS
SSIA HAS  UKRAINE.
>>OUE GAG
RIOTING BR,
I DON'T. BO INTO THE
CAPITOL UNR THE CIRCUMSTANCES AS
HA FE TOPREDSI>> MORE NOOM
ET'S SH THE REPUBLICANS BOTHTHT
AND THE HOE.JUST HEARD FROM SOM.
ROMNEY, ATWHIKE SENATOMI
BEEN PRETTN AGAINSRMER PRESIDEN
SEBLIKEEN  HAWLEY SH
S POSITI HE
TO
AND WHAT WAGAIN AND
AGAIN INNG WITE
BLD
BACK AGAINST AND HAD VERY
DIFFERENT OPIO
PRESIDENT TRUMP, IT REALLY KIND
OF C AROUNE SU UKRAINE
PUTIN, AND IF HEA WAR
CRIMINALR O SHOULD
WIN THAT WAR.
ITAS JANUARYthORMER
AVE BECONVICTED AND ARE SERVINGH
EILING WHICHM VERSUS
WORK TOWARDS THAT JUNE 1
DEADNE NATION
TOLT. REALLY THWE ALSO HEARD SI
FROM MEMBEF GOP O KINDF  BAC TH
SAME ISSUES ASEL
E REPUBLICANS
NG OUT AGAINST THE
PRESIDENT,
HANDFUL OF PD
HE STILL HAS AMOOFER ANDN
SYSTEM HERAMONRE
NDT ABOUT REACTION
>> WELL,S U CA MOCRATS HAVE NEV
OF THE FORMER PRESIDENT, AND
TH.HE DEMOCRAC Y TTACDONALDRU,
UB H U WELL, THAT IS
THE CASE THEY' MAKING.
WE HEARD THE SENATE MAJORITY CK
OUT HOW WHAT ECALLTH
HAS ENORMOUS S
HOUSE SPEAKER KEVIN McCA A DEBTN
NEGOTIAT
M HAKEEM JEFFRIESS
S.THAT THIS WAS
EXHIBIT A OF T TRAUMA THAT
AMERICA WOULSEE IF WE HAVE
ANOTHER FOUR YEARSITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
AND THEN WE AL FROM
AT RE TO PARDON THOSE E
JANUARY OTERS,ET
IN HIS EYES.
A LOT FRHED EXPECT, LY TRYING
SIONS AND
QU E IT VE CLEAR TT THEY ARE
MOCRATS OFA VERY, VERY,
VERY DIFFERENT VIEW THAN DONALD
FAR RIGHT WING OF THHI THA
AL, ANON
TOO  TREPUANE SECOND WE E SENAT
LIKE A L  ADS WE N LA
LINE" OF.A DEAPPRECIATE IT. WITG
ARUC OWN
HOUSE CORRESPONDENPHIL MTINGLY.
DO YOU THINKG S N THE PAST 24 H
THAT HAS CHANGEDYN
FOR THISOP R>>.
BUT I THK YO ARE
BRINGING UP SOMETHING THAT COULD
AND THAT IUGHT OF NATORS AND HO
PR
IDTHINK THAT WOULDE A SNBA
ROLLIN AT
TILL FEA HSTOP
THTANTS ARE A BIG BULLY
TELLING THEM SAY ANYTHING
T KE
STAND  THE MITT ROMNEY DID, A G
YL
"THE WIZARD OF OZ," THE WATER
ACALLY SLLD SHE STARTED MELTING
TH TURNETO DM SORRY
AT WE DID THIS.K WE'R
HEWATETOE
HAS TO START MELTING,
HAVE TO SHOW SOMBR
COURAGE.
ON CAPH.E THEY REALLY READY TOA?
>> MORE IN THEOU
WO THE SENATE,
ELECTORACEHAT IT
TAKES TO HAVE POLITICAL COURAGE
AND MORAL COUR?
E ARE U.S. SENORHAEEELD O
-- WHOBSE
EVERYTHING SENATOR TILL
DT REALLY SUPPORT  INSURRECTIO
YEARS,E HAVE TT,ANTHONY.S THE M
AN BCLED GOING TO
HAS TLI
REPUBLICAN, BECAUSE THE PRM
RIGHT NOW IS THAT HE I AS A
DEMOCR THE OTHAT'SMBOLDENING HI
REPUBLICAN TO DONALD
BUILDING A WED ANDTUM FOR SO
ELSE. HEHE BIDEN WHITE HOUSEHT G
E ATTACK ADS THAT
IT?ST NIGHT BECAUS S LIED. O
A
I THINK THE REPUAN
SENATOREE GOOD
AT KIND OF S
EN YOU TAKE
TH  VERY OF ST NIGHT, ON SD
WET AND UNDERSTAND IT.YOU ADDRE
YOT
CONTENT, SUBSTICY
ASSSED THROUGHHE
QU KAITLAN WAS
NG, U  THE PRESIDENTMP WAS
FRAMING OF PRESIDENT B
ISE RUN ONEELECTION  STAKES OF
AND WON ON BH IN THE MIDTERM
ELECTIONS AND THE WISCONSIN
STATEWIDEMI
YOU  AT SWING STATES ON TH
WINNING ISSUE ERDAY OF THE
E FORM
AND PARSE ONE WANTA
BAN ALL HE
WAS.E SAID ON DOBBS,G
CLEAR W PROU W
DEMOCRAT IN AMICRITING A
CAMPAIGN ISSUE ON THAT AD., AN
ED AND SAID THIS WAS TH OF
O